it was conservative party members who
catapulted Liz truss into the top job as
she arrived at the hustings in Leeds
back in July the support for her was
evident but it is those same party
members that are now questioning her
leadership
four Liz trust backers who were there
that day are still supporting her but
only just the steps were taken too fast
I think
yes he should I would not say apologize
but at least she should accept it that
whatever they did was was not was not
right and that's why they are in in that
situation she should accept it is this
the least trust that you wanted in power
um
not 100 no I have to be honest here she
went too fast you know she should have
implemented
um the the policies and the budget maybe
at a slower Tempo mistakes made at the
start of her Premiership but still no
apology that lack of remorse is noted
would you like to see her apologize for
the mistakes made yeah I think she has
to do that at this moment because of so
many controversies at his was hurt when
the country's first black Chancellor
quasiquarten was sacrificed after just
38 days in the job of course I was a bit
worried about quartering being dismissed
and I just thought about the policies on
inclusion which is a good picture for
like the opposition but now with Jeremy
Hunt in number 11 it's brought back bits
of confidence for some I've worked with
Jeremy Jeremy is is that kind of a
person who's committed committed to
taking the country forward this is
though a party very much divided
Samina Fields they need to be flexible
there's anybody in the park
in just six short weeks Liz truss has
succeeded in concerning all wings of her
party it's clear from even her most
devoted members that Faith support and
Trust they once had isn't all there into
man Rashid Sky News Manchester